he is one of the top players in the
national football league as a matter of
fact he's made the top 10 on the top 100
nfl list an nfl network and that gets
revealed coming up this weekend
played in the super bowl last year won
it two years ago and uh despite all of
his excellence on the field and off the
field as a community man
uh
he lights up the internet because he
decides to shave his face it's insane
the world that this man lives but we
always appreciate when travis kelsey
calls into the rich eyes of joe how are
you travis
rich fellas how are we doing today guys
it's uh it's a beautiful day out here in
kansas city got a nice clean shaved face
really you're not growing up you're not
growing it back like you're not you're
you're not starting from you're not
you're starting from scratch every day
like literally you know what really yeah
after that picture i realized you know
what i need to really embrace who i am
and uh looking at myself in the mirror
really motivates me to you know i mean
keep doing the right things in life
um
going to work
playing hard
being selfless you know right that's
what it's all about man but what a pain
in the ass it is to do that every day if
you don't have to i mean right it's
maintenance
oh man to be honest right now i'm just
torturing my girlfriend because she's
she's not a fan of just the the shave
face
the baby face oh my god it's kind of
it's kind of poking poking the bear
right now it's just having fun travis
it's not even popular at home too you're
getting it on twitter and you're getting
it really it's not even yeah no i'm
getting uppercuts and just left hooks
from from everybody that's good though
it's good fun it's good fun and i'm
enjoying every bit of it dude seriously
what's it like when you're you you look
at your phone and people are like what
the hell just happened and you're like
walk me through the process of how it
led to you defacing your own selfie and
using it as your avatar walk me through
that process please
travis
well i i couldn't even tell you man i
just jumped on social media and after uh
after a hard training camp day i mean
like i feel like it was about 110
degrees outside like
i'm going to grab lunch and i just so
happened to throw twitter uh or throw
twitter on the phone i just started
scrolling and i was like man a lot of
people are talking about this terrible
picture i just
wonder i
wonder how this is going to go over yeah
and and sure enough like
within the
within the next like two days i mean
every single espn nfl
you name it shade room every every
single social media outlet had wrote
something
just hilarious just and i i i was just i
was in a frenzy man i was caught in the
wash and you know all you can do at that
point is just laugh it off man just you
know learn to live
you know fight another day
and then deface your selfie and own it
that's what you need to do no did you
that's the thing that was also the other
part man you know they just own it man
you just own it because you know we did
the same fight
once you fight it yeah social media is
just going to turn it up a whole nother
level well you know we did it too we
defaced our we drew we drew beards on
ourselves that's still up on our youtube
page that's still up on our youtube
header that's that's how you bring a
community together right now
and that's why i love you guys that's
why i'm here that's why i'm here that's
why i'm on the right side
oh
man travis kelsey here on the rich house
show and one other thing that i kind of
want to hit with you i don't know if i
heard this or not i think i heard this
is it true your your name isn't really
pronounced kelsey it's kels and somebody
calls it kelsey is that true did i hear
that i mean so is there a truth to it
yes there is there is a lot of truth to
it so
there was a i was on uh taylor lawan's
podcast yes
absolutely butchered his last name and
i've known him for years i felt like an
idiot when i when i said leewan yes and
uh he called me out on it and i was just
like man you know what people have been
saying my name wrong the whole time
too
and there is some truth to it everybody
on my father's side has said kels
my entire life um but my father growing
up just kind of got lazy and
didn't really want to keep uh correcting
everybody that was calling him kelsey
so he just went along with kelsey so i
had my father working hard work from
home
and answer the phone calls every single
time somebody would call it yellow ed
kelsey so i mean my name is
kelsey i'm rolling with what my dad says
what my brother says okay um shout out
to all the kelseys
that are in the family tree i hope i'm
not we're not pissing you off but so
it's really it's it's a silent e on your
family tree so it's a family tree is
basically what you're saying
the kels family truck
right yeah
okay
because i'm trying i don't even know you
can keep calling me travis kelsey okay
because it's good because with your with
what papa kel's turned it into after
hearing this on on uh on taylor's
podcast the busting with the boys i i
gotta mention oh by the way you gotta
you gotta you gotta mention compton too
right i mean because he gets he gets
really pissed right there he gets really
pissed and and i kind of like always
like forgetting him i like i like
leaving him off they go yeah it's it's
little it's taylor lewand's podcast
because once i by the way and
after hearing that and then seeing you
shave i've thought i don't even know who
the hell travis kelsey is anymore you
know like my whole world is off its axis
i didn't even know what the hell was
going on right there i'm walking around
kansas city just blending in with the
trees
nobody even knows
that tall guy with a shaved face with
the shaved face he looks familiar but i
can't pick it out yeah where do you
think travis kelsey here on the rich
eyes here where do you think you're
going to be on the top 10 list what do
you got one let's say it come on what do
you think i'm just i'm just you know i'm
i'm very honored to even you know be
recognized within the top ten i mean on
the hunter
it's it's such a it's such a team driven
sport rich you know a lot of the
individual accolades you know they're
cool at the end of the day
and when you're everything's said and
done but
what's real is that you know i'm not the
same player without a guy named patrick
mahomes and irish hill and coach andy
reid so
you know it's just uh it's it's me
thanking
everybody you know for for doing their
job and help making my life so easy on
the football field and help making this
team better now let's let's just though
really just act like that's just the two
of us talking here and there's nobody
else listening even despite the fact
it's an international audience but let's
just say
what would it mean if you wound up
higher on the list than mahomes though
how great would that be oh my gosh
i don't know if i would ever let him
i would just tell him you need me every
day i'm like you need me honestly how
amazing
would that be if it winds up
well oh my gosh i might even go on
twitter and say this list is just
bananas this is ridiculous i'm sick of
seeing guys placed anywhere sure
oh that would be wonderful though i
would be rich
would it not be i would just i'm so
rooting for you on that front
that would be great i would just be my
eyes peeled on on this weekend and just
hope i hear mahomes his name before
kelsey that would be amazing and um my
son did choose you uh fifth overall in
his fantasy draft my ten-year-old uh
yes and we he because he he came up uh
last year uh because he likes having
puns for his fantasy team names and
things like that like tell it to the
judge is his fantasy baseball because
he's got aaron judge on it so the name
of his team his name of the team are you
ready for this travis ready
i'm waiting on it two kelsey for comfort
that's the name of his team
two calcium
yeah i like that that's pretty clever
there you go pretty clever yeah his dad
came up with it he had no idea he had no
idea work with that one
i came up with it he really didn't know
he doesn't remember what two coats for
comfort is or anything like that but he
loves it he's fired up man so you're not
just playing for the chiefs you're
playing for two kelsey for comfort i
just want you to be aware of that you
get a good name you're in it
this is how fantasy football works here
we go you got a bad name you might as
well just not even look every single
week okay i've got a couple of football
questions for you travis kelsey here
here they come here they come here's the
first one
um uh how in the world do you improve on
anything it just seems that you know i
understand last year
um you didn't finish up with the you
picking confetti out of your hair but it
just seems to be so terrific and
everybody seems to be getting better i
mean honestly what what what is it like
to be pushing the same rock up the same
hill and hoping to get a uh one
different result
on the on the weight loss what's that
like travis kelsey well one thing one
thing
about football is that you're non-stop
you can always find something to get
better at it's just there's never
you never have seen all the reps that
you're going to see out on the football
field at all always plays out
differently um even when you think you
got something schemed up and everything
just plays out always just a little bit
different so building the instincts to
always have something in your back
pocket uh to to to refer to or just you
know have instinctual uh visualizations
and stuff like that i'm always trying to
find other ways to to win my router to
make the block uh things like that so
that's always you know taking me to the
next level or trying to get me over the
hump to the next level um in every ass
aspect of the game but i think coach
reed does an unbelievable job every
single year year and year out of
creating a playbook uh that we can grow
in so it's not the same stuff that we've
been we've been
throwing out there so we can get schemed
up and it makes our job harder it's
actually um he's putting in new stuff
he's putting in things that are you know
going to make our jobs that much easier
out there on the field to put us in a
position to have success and when we rep
all these all these plays in practice we
find ways
to have success versus various coverages
and i think that's where i really grow
every single year is within this offense
and uh going out there and just trying
to make the best play for for the team
man what's it like to get one of those
new plays from reed have you had one of
those moments like where the hell oh man
oh and and obviously you know uh eric b
enemy and it's a staff um contribution
but when you get one of them and
have you had moments like wow i didn't
think of that like how do they think of
of that do you um have that stuff or no
not really no we definitely we got some
wacky stuff in the in the in the
playbook now we got some gadget stuff
that you wouldn't even think would be on
a football field
um
but it's it's it's fun man i tell
everybody all the time and wednesdays
might be my second favorite day of the
week outside of sundays or player game
day because when the wednesdays that
that wednesday installs that base game
plan the the majority of the plays that
you're gonna get and it's just exciting
to hear coach reid you know explain what
how we're going to attack this team and
uh and and and with what parts and with
what routes and what run plays and stuff
like that um
it's just it it's exciting for me and i
mean i i feel like with with my homes it
expanded even more so four three four
years ago whenever pat got here um
everything started to expand and even
even alex's last year started to expand
downfield with the players that we had
with tyreek hill and all the speed we
had it's just been a whole lot of fun
just you know
hearing coach reed get excited about a
play call and then finally getting it
called in the game and going for six man
it's just uh
it's it's it's a time warp that i love
being in there no and and and the
question you know you bring up alex
smith and patrick mahomes few minutes
left here with travis kelsey on the rich
eisen show and i don't i'm gonna i'm
gonna ask the question and this is not
at all in any way shape or form to see
if alex smith
shouldn't have started that whole first
season as mahomes was just drafted
at all okay and uh that's my front load
of this thing because i i'm asking this
question merely because we're seeing
naggy matt neggy who was on the staff
that year now in chicago trying to
replicate something
where he's got a new jewel right that he
just traded up to go get in the first
round just like the chiefs did with
mahomes
do you think mahomes needed
that time to become the mahomes he is
today travis best you can tell having a
front row seat
for all of that what do you think i'm a
little biased i'm a little biased that's
a great question i'm a little biased in
who patrick mahomes is
um i think i saw it from the get-go his
determination his
his ability to uh see
see coverages early feel confident in
what he's seen be able to throw a good
ball
um and then obviously is his ability to
make plays when the play breaks down
it's just
it's it's second to none that i've ever
played with or ever seen on the field so
it's i'm a little biased when i say i
don't think he needed that year
but i do think that it helped him be
ready for the next season but more than
anything without a doubt him
understanding uh alex's is his
professionalism just how to be a pro um
it's reassuring
it it gives you that confidence that
okay i know how to do this this is a guy
who's had success in the league for
numerous years almost a decade now and
this and and this he does it like this i
can see how he has success and turn it
into my own madness and my own psychic
and and i think that really helped him
but at the same time when you talk about
needed i don't know man patrick holmes
got something about him that i think uh
he'll he was gonna find a way um it
might not have been early as as fast as
uh the 50 touchdowns his first season
starting or 55 touchdowns the first
season started it might not have been
something like that um but it would i
think he would have still had or found
success uh
what about like huddle command what
about huddle command and having the play
call and knowing it and being able to
deliver it in a manner in the huddle
that that uh communicated rather than
just memorizing it and spitting it out
and stuff like that all things yeah
those are all things that first-year
quarterbacks and first-year united
players all struggle with getting in out
of the huddle being confident with what
they're seeing what they know right
other progression and stuff like that um
i think it definitely helped him like i
said it definitely helped him um but pat
was always pretty good uh just in terms
of being uh being on top of the play
calling um and understanding where he
needs to go versus what coverage is and
stuff like that as always before i let
you go i want to give you the floor on
your uh your charitable works your
foundation whatever you're up to and how
anyone who's listening uh can be a part
what you're doing there nice and i
appreciate that
87 and running.com or i believe
exactly.org you can just go on my social
media and click the uh the link in the
bio yep um it's
i've been so fortunate to get the the
community support um people supported
doing the the right things for these
kids in this community in kansas city in
cleveland ohio where i'm from um
actually in the the second week of
september we are opening uh the ignition
lab that i i bought a muffler uh shop
right next to operation breakthrough
which is a a
a school that helps out underprivileged
kids um throughout the community um and
it's just it's something that i've seen
kids grow through my entire
years here in kansas city and um the the
program ended in eighth grade while i
was able to buy this shopping um with
kansas city support we're able to to
find the funds to to create this after
school
stem lab
opportunities for these high school kids
so
they'll go to operation breakthrough
through eighth grade and then they'll
finally go to this ignition lab um well
they'll they'll be able to you know
just be
high school kids in the very controlled
environment off the streets doing the
right things and then have a goal in
mind uh with the stem labs that are that
are going to be in
um the ignition lab so it's just uh it's
it's a whole lot of fun and i'm excited
and like i said you could find the 87
and running in my uh any of my social
media um
bios
well uh travis always appreciate the
time congratulations in advance and
being the you know inaugural member of
to kelsey for comfort um i hope you ball
out uh on that front you're welcome uh
we'll be keeping a close eye on your
beard uh and your shaving habits i know
that sounds odd but you know what i'm
talking about what's going on in the
world
um and and just uh in general uh i
appreciate you and your time and i i
sure as hell hope to hear the word
mahomes before kelsey on nfl network
coming up that would be just
amazing i would i would look forward to
it but i'm i'm listening in on all these
on all these episodes big guy i love
listening to you guys thanks man i
appreciate that you're the best travis
kelsey you bet let's chat down the line
that's the one and only travis kelsey
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here